josh lindbloom back from the bereavement
list he's making the start today
yeah last time out his last thought was
back on september 9th
strikes out perez for out number two
breaking balls galore for
limb bloom he's got an arsenal of
different off-speed pitches he throws
six pitches all together
limb bloom steps off the rubber they've
got monday in a rundown
throw to second kira flies the tag and
that's how the inning ends
trying to get limb bloom to block and he
wouldn't do it
brad keller has not allowed a home run
in his 43 and two-thirds innings and
he's only given up two extra base hits
yeah i mean he's been phenomenal
oh did not make a good throw and nikki
lopez
who either had his foot on the bag or
applied the tag but he go to sound hard
it's almost like mejia lost track of the
house because if you're going for two
there you'd expect a little
firmer throw from the third baseman to
the second baseman that was not
pretty didn't have his feet under him at
all
oh like short on he just kind of tried
to
he didn't throw it dude he kind of
babied it over there and that's
really a vulnerable spot there for a
second basement you hope nikki's okay
now it looks like his left ankle might
have taken the brunt of that
shot there but man that was dangerous
here's the 3-2
vogel back to center way back
vogel back has gone deep again second
time
in this home stand how about pizza ranch
who never
fails does it first home that look that
keller has given up this year
gotta go back to august ninth of last
year left home running allowed and
vogelback taking him deep
that was a blast way back in center
instead of pop-up on the infield that'll
work
into right center long run peterson able
to make the catch
boy did he eat a good a great jump on
that plane right
[Music]
and mirrorfield off the end of the bat
kira's right there
and it's another zero for josh lindbloom
in the third
works around that lead off base head
3-2 is swung on and missed and a good
slider from
keller there's his second strikeout on
the day as he gets here
with a first down in inning number four
there's a swing and a miss at a fastball
up and a strikeout for
keller that is his third and a second
straight one two three inning
there's a good looking swing good call
hud not only does mejia
have his first hit today but it's going
to be an extra base hit
and he'll stop at second base with a
lead-off double there you go
gotta have a batting average his
teammates are happy for him that's a
pretty good swing
he able to drive that one into the gap
lead off double
here's the ground ball to the right side
so it's an out but it gets mejia to
third
up the middle the brewers will take the
out the royals will take the run
so the royals had gone 14 consecutive
innings
without scoring a run and mejia's lead
op double makes it 2-1
2-1 brewers looking to add on against
keller who's gotten better as the game
has progressed
yelich with a shot to right a base hit
for christian
good start to the sixth inning for the
brewery's offense
to left to base hit squared up that
breaking ball
you can't be hanging breaking pitches to
brian braun i don't care what the count
is he's gonna barrel it up
so the brewers have two on with nobody
out in the sixth
and that'll bring up daniel vogelbeck
who has accounted for both milwaukee
runs with a two-run homer in the first
inning
to left-center deep he's done it again
daniel vogelback has provided all the
offense for the crew this afternoon
what a story that's a pretty good pickup
i'd say
my goodness five rbis for vogelback
this one a 3-2 pitch
way back to the opposite field
here comes ryan braun played in the
organization
for 14 years ryan braun potentially his
last ever game
at miller park yeah i mean obviously
it's a bit of an emotional day i think
it would be a lot different if there
were fans here
you know the whole experience this year
feels drastically different than
any uh normal or regular baseball season
would obviously for for so many reasons
but certainly there's so many uh
incredible moments and memories
um that i've had an opportunity to be a
part of here in this ballpark so
i definitely want to take it in a little
bit just enjoy it and reflect a little
bit today
crazy to think he might end it as a dh
no why not
in the national league a one to him
chopper third base side
[Applause]
no play it's a base hit for brawn
so the line drive that was right at the
center fielder kind of
that equals out yeah they even out don't
they rock
[Music]
it looks like a rocket in the book
that's what he's telling jason lane
right now i'm sure
salvi blasts it to left field
and that is gone into the second deck
and the royals keep it interesting in
the ninth inning
that's his first hit today it is his
eighth home run
and craig council gets back on the phone
as it becomes
a save situation now it is 5-3 in the
ninth
josh hayder to try and put the finishing
touches on this sweep against kansas
city
dozier pops it up arcia
with plenty of room makes the call makes
the catch and the brewers finish off the
sweep of kansas city
a 5-3 final vogelback
put the exclamation point on this one
driving in five with two home runs and
ryan braun potentially
his last game ever at miller park
finishes off with a victory